[Music]
god is dead
god remains dead
and we have killed him friedrich
nietzsche wrote in 1882
to understand what the german
philosopher meant and what he thought of
men morality and society as a whole we
collaborated with professor stephen
hicks on this sprout special series
[Music]
part one
god is dead
[Music]
for thousands of years humans have been
religious but in the modern world
religion has become a shadow of its
former self
nietzsche's dramatic phrase
god is dead is meant to capture the
shocking quality of this revelation
for those raised religiously religion
personalized the world it gave them a
sense that the world had a purpose and
that they were part of a larger plan
it gave them the comfort that despite
appearances we are all equal and cared
for and that upon death instead of a
cold grave a possible happily ever after
ending awaits
but in the modern world we find it
increasingly hard to believe those
values we have seen the dramatic rise of
science which has offered less
comfortable answers to questions
religion traditionally had a monopoly on
we have thrown off the shackles of
feudalism with its unquestioning
acceptance of authority and have become
more individualistic and naturalistic in
our thinking
but in historical time all of this has
happened very quickly
[Music]
for millennia we have been religious but
come the 19th century even the average
man had heard that religion may have
reached the end of its journey
for most of us even the suggestion of
this hints at a crisis
imagine a 13 year old who is awakened in
the middle of the night to be told by
strangers that both his parents have
died
he is suddenly an orphan for as long as
he can remember his mother and father
were present in his life
looking after him and guiding him
now they are gone and ready or not he is
thrust into that world alone
how does the young teen handle that
sudden transition
culturally nietzsche says we are like
that young teen
for as long as we can remember our
society has relied upon god the father
to look after us
but now suddenly we are orphaned
we wake up one morning to discover that
in our heart of hearts our naively
childhood religious beliefs have
withered
so now whether we like it or not a
question creeps into our minds
how do we face the prospect of a world
without god and religion
in the 19th century says nietzsche most
people did not face that question well
most people avoid the issue sensing that
even to raise it would be to enter
dangerous territory
life without religion is too scary to
contemplate so they retreat to a safety
zone of belief and repeat nervously the
formulas they have learned about faith
slightly better to nietzsche but not
much are the socialists of the 19th
century
socialism is on the rise and many
socialists accept that god is dead
but then they are very concerned that
the state take god's place and look
after them
the mighty state will provide for us and
tell us what to do against the mean
people of the world
think of it this way the judeo-christian
tradition says this is a world of sin in
which the weak suffer at the hands of
the strong that we should all be
selfless and serve god and others
especially the sick and helpless
and that in a future ideal world heaven
the lion will lie down with lamb and the
inescapable power of god will bring
salvation to the meek and judgment to
the wicked
[Music]
the socialist tradition says this is a
world of evil exploitation in which the
strong take advantage of the weak
but we should all be selfless and
sacrifice for the good of others
especially the needy from each according
to his ability to each according to his
need
and the forces of history will
necessarily bring about a future ideal
world that will end all harsh
competition empowering the oppressed and
eliminating the evil exploiters
both religion and socialism thus glorify
weakness and need
both recoil from the world as it is
tough unequal
harsh
both flee to an imaginary future realm
where they can feel safe both say be a
nice boy be a good little girl
share
feel sorry for the little people and
both desperately seek someone to look
after them whether it be god or the
state
so where asks nature are the men of
courage who is willing to stare into the
abyss who can stand alone on the icy
mountain top who can look at tiger in
the eye without flinching
to be continued
nietzsche who was born in 1884 was not
only a fierce critic of church and
socialism but also nationalism and
anti-semitism
his strong moral stance meant that he
openly condemned many of his
intellectual friends and even broke his
relationship with his own sister who
married a notorious anti-semite
so what are your thoughts on nietzsche
do you agree with his understanding of
the world we live in for more
information about this extraordinary man
and his impact on our society
check the descriptions below
there you'll also find a link to stephen
hicks full account of the german
philosopher
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts